REPORTS.
IN ONE TOWN, PARENTS EVEN BEGAN
TARGETING THE CHILD OF THE BOARD
CHAIRWOMAN.
>> Reporter: KELSEY AND THEIR
KIDS ABBY AND KIT LIVE IN THEIR
DREAM HOUSE IN HASTINGS,
MINNESOTA.
FOR A FEW MORE WEEKS ANYWAY.
>> LOOK AT THE STEAM ON THAT
ONE.
WHEN I LEFT THE NAVY, WHEN I
LEFT ACTIVE DUTY, I HAD A JOB
OPPORTUNITY HERE AND I FLEW OUT.
KELSEY SAID, WELL, I HOPE THE
INTERVIEW WENT WELL BECAUSE
WE'RE MOVING HERE.
THIS TOWN IS GREAT.
THIS TOWN IS PERFECT.
THIS IS WHAT I WANT.
>> HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
HASTINGS NOW?
>> I CAN'T UNSEE THE THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN SENT TO ME.
I THINK WITH TIME I WILL FIND
FORGIVENESS.
>> Reporter: KELSEY IS ONE OF
THOSE SCHOOL BOARD INCUMBENTS
DEFEATED THIS YEAR BY PARENTS
ANGRY OVER MASK RULES.
>> MASKS SHOULD BE A PARENT'S
DECISION.
>> Reporter: AND DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION PROGRAMS.
>> THIS COMMUNITY WAS VERY
SPLIT.
>> Reporter: SHE VOTE FORWARD
MASKING.
SHE SUPPORTED DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION PROGRAMS.
CHOICES THAT ENERGIZE PARENTS IN
A FACEBOOK GROUP OPPOSED TO
PANDEMIC RESTRICTIONS.
THE GROUP WAS FORMED IN JULY
UNDER THE NAME CONSERVATIVE
PARENTS OF HASTINGS.
A FEW WEEKS LATER THE NAME WAS
CHANGED TO CONCERNED PARENTS OF
HASTINGS.
IT'S A SMALL TOWN.
SHE KNOWS A LOT OF THE PARENTS
IN THIS GROUP.
>> I'M FINE WITH THAT.
THAT'S POLITICS.
>> Reporter: ONE DAY, A PARENT
WROTE A LONG POST COMPLAINING
ABOUT KELSEY AND MASKING.
AND THE REPLIES, THINGS GOT
UGLY.
>> SOMEONE RESPONDED TO THAT
POST BY SAYING KELSEY NEEDS TO
BE IN JAIL BECAUSE HER YOUNGEST
DAUGHTER IS A BOY.
>> Reporter: A PARENT OUTED KIT
BECAUSE OF KIT'S MOM'S POLITICS.
>> THIS WAS MY MOST PRECIOUS
SECRET.
THE THING I PROTECTED MOST AND
THE THING I WAS MOST AFRAID OF
EVER BEING USED IN A POLITICAL
WAY.
I DROPPED TO THE FLOOR AND I
CRIED.
>> Reporter: OTHER PARENTS SOON
PILED ON.
ONE ATTACKED THE WAITS, CALLING
THEM WOKE PARENTS.
ANOTHER WROTE MY HEART BREAKS
FOR ANY CHILD WHO HAS PARENTS
THAT PUSH THE [ BLEEP ] ON THEM.
ONE MODERATOR OF THE GROUP HID
SOME OF THE UGLY POSTS BUT
ANOTHER MODERATOR POSTED MORE.
IT KEPT GOING.
>> IT'S JUST A KID TRYING TO
IMPRESS THEIR WOKE PARENTS.
AND I'M LIKE, MY GOD, I VOTED
FOR BUSH, BUT EVERY TIME HE WAS
ON THE BALLOT.
MY WOKENESS, IF YOU WANT TO SAY
THAT MY UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT
IS TO BE TRANSGENDER MAKES ME
WOKE, IT'S BECAUSE KIT WOKE ME
UP.
KIT TAUGHT ME NOT THE OTHER WAY
AROUND.
>> Reporter: KIT IS 8 YEARS OLD.
USES THE PRONOUNS THEY/THEM.
THE WAITS HAVE ASKED WE NOT SHOW
THEIR FACE ON CAMERA.
>> I LIKE THAT YOUR SOCKS NEVER
MATCH.
>> KIT ASKED FOR ONE THING.
THEY REALLY, REALLY WANTED THE
KIT KITRIDGE AMERICAN GIRL DOLL.
I WAS STANDING RIGHT THERE IN
THE KITCHEN AND KIT WALKS UP TO
ME.
AND GOES, MOM, CAN YOU CALL ME
KIT.
AND I SAID, SURE.
STILL MY LITTLE BOY?
AND KIT GOES, NO, YOUR LITTLE
GIRL.
AND I WAS LIKE ABSOLUTELY,
SWEETIE, YOU GOT IT.
AND THEN I RAN INTO THE OTHER
ROOM WITH A PANIC ATTACK AND
CALLED DADDY IN JAPAN AND SAID,
WHAT THE HECK JUST HAPPENED?
>> Reporter: IT WAS A JOURNEY
FOR THESE PARENTS.
>> I REMEMBER A CONVERSATION
WITH A FAMILY MEMBER THAT SAID
HAVE YOU EVER JUST CONSIDERED
DOING MORE MANLY THINGS WITH KIT
AND LESS NURTURY THINGS.
AND AT THAT MOMENT IT WAS KIND
OF A, WELL, WAIT A MINUTE, WHAT
AM I TRYING TO DO HERE AND WHAT
IS REALLY -- WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THIS?
>> Reporter: THE WAITS DECIDED
THE RIGHT COURSE WAS LOVE YOUR
KID.
THEY LET KIT BE KIT.
>> WE LOST OUR FRIENDS WHEN KIT
FIRST CAME OUT AND WE LOST
FAMILY.
>> Reporter: THE FAMILY KEPT ALL
OF THIS A SECRET FROM MOST
PEOPLE.
FOR A SIMPLE REASON.
SAFETY.
>> YOU OUT A KID BEFORE THEY'RE
READY, YOU'RE SUBJECTING THEM TO
THAT SORT OF BEHAVIOR THAT'S
GOING TO INCREASE THEIR RISK OF
SUICIDE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT MY PARENTING
PRACTICES.
THIS IS ABOUT THE LIVES OF KIDS.
>> Reporter: AFTER KIT WAS OUTED
ONLINE, KELSEY REALIZED THE
FAMILY MIGHT NOT BE SAFE.
SHE WROTE A LETTER TO THE LOCAL
NEWSPAPER.
SHE APPEALED TO DECENCY.
>> I BASICALLY SAID THERE'S
STILL A LINE.
DON'T CROSS THE LINE.
AND THEN I CONTINUED MY LATER
SAYING, HERE ARE THE GREAT
THINGS.
HERE'S HOW WE COME TOGETHER AS A
COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: ON FACEBOOK, SOME
PARENTS RESPONDED.
WITH GLEE.
WE MADE THE PAPER, ONE PARENT
WROTE.
>> THEY ARE PROUD OF WHAT THEY
DID.
>> Reporter: CNN REACHED OUT TO
PARENTS IN THE GROUP.
WE REACHED OUT TO THE
MODERATORS.
NO ONE RESPONDED.
BUT CONCERNED PARENTS OF
HASTINGS BLOCKED US.
SHE KNOWS THESE PARENTS.
SHE SEES THEM IN THE GROCERY
STORE.
THEY KNOW EACH OTHER.
AND YET WHEN IT CAME TO A
POLITICAL DEBATE, THEY CHOSE TO
OUT HER CHILD.
HOW DO YOU SEE THAT HAPPENING?
WHERE DOES THAT COME FROM?
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> I THINK THERE'S BEEN A
BEHAVIOR LIKE THAT THAT'S BEEN
MODELED BY A LOT OF POLITICIANS
IN THE UNITED STATES OVER THE
PAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND I THINK NORMAL PEOPLE WHO
ARE LOOKING AT THESE SMALL
ISSUES AT THEIR SCHOOL BOARD, IN
THEIR LOCAL ELECTIONS SAY, WELL,
THERE'S NOT A CONSEQUENCE FOR
THOSE PEOPLE AND I'M JUST A
SMALL FRY SO THERE'S NOT GOING
TO BE A CONSEQUENCE FOR ME.
>> Reporter: THIS FAMILY IS NOT
STICKING AROUND THIS
NEIGHBORHOOD TO FIND OUT WHAT
COMES NEXT.
THEY ARE MOVING.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT RIGHT
NOW.
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WE
KNOW THAT ARE NOT SAFE FOR OUR
KIDS IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND THAT WE CAN'T TRUST OUR KIDS
ALONE AT THE BUS STOP WAITING
FOR THE BUS.
NOT BECAUSE OF T